the complex relationship between master
chief and his ai partner cortana has
always been one of the strongest driving
forces for the halo franchise it's a
genuine bond but one born out of
manipulation as cortana is gifted to
chief as a perfect companion to ensure
he maintains peak efficiency as a super
soldier in this way cortana has always
been the more dominant voice in the
partnership she tells chief where to go
and what to do and chief
single-mindedness coupled with the
ability to solely rely on her means he
never has to develop emotionally healthy
bonds with normal human beings halo
infant is the first time we've seen the
power dynamics of chief's relationship
with an ai flipped creating an
intriguing new take for spartan 117
paired with a new ai simply named the
weapon chief takes on a more fatherly
figure in infinite where cortana is
assertive quick-witted and mature the
weapon is awkward overly trusting and
silly she sounds and acts like a
child-like version of cortana pushing
chief into taking on a more domineering
role that has far more control over her
agency this opens new opportunities for
a halo story in a franchise that has
long had an undercurrent theme of
familial connections in motherhood
infinite is the first in the series to
focus its narrative around familial
responsibility and fatherhood the
strength of that narrative alongside the
open world and new traversal mechanics
delivers a welcoming freshness to the
two decades old series
[Music]
other than chief halo infinite doesn't
have much in the way familiar faces very
early into the campaign you're
confronted with the startling reveal
that a lot of the folks you've come to
know over previous games are dead or
missing in action chief finds himself on
a new halo ring named zeta halo which
has been partially destroyed the
banished an independent army of multiple
alien species that splintered off of the
covenant want the ring for some unknown
purpose and she fails to stop them
without any of his usual allies to turn
to chief ropes two unwitting companions
into his fight the aforementioned weapon
who was supposed to delete herself all
in completion of her purpose and the
pilot a man desperately trying to just
get home to unsc space after being
stranded the first half of act 1 and
most of act 3 are traditional halo
contained linear levels where you're
guided through gauntlets of enemies the
rest of the game incorporates a hybrid
open world you're able to freely move
through a wide open area and pursue
optional side missions or beeline for
the next main story objective reaching
those objectives typically funnels you
back into the more traditional halo
level design only for chief to emerge
into the open world again once the
mission is complete in this way infinite
maintains the cinematic quality of
halo's traditionally linear campaigns
while also incorporating an open world
to explore those optional side missions
bring aspects of halo's multiplayer into
infinite's campaign creating scenarios
in which players can approach a problem
in numerous ways each of which can lead
to satisfying and occasionally hilarious
outcomes experimentation is often
rewarded with satisfying victory or a
story of how everything went hilariously
wrong regardless of the approach taken
it's fun to dismantle the banished
encampments on zeta halo wrestling
control away from them slowly but surely
even on infinite's harder difficulties
you can easily skip over all the
optional missions and still get that
linear halo experience if you want but
infinite provides compelling reasons for
stepping off the main path in a first
for halo there's an in-game progression
system in the campaign completing tasks
like saving captured unsc soldiers and
destroying banished roadblocks or
refineries nets you valor which unlocks
new vehicles and weapons that can be
summoned at forward operating bases
across the map allowing you to bring
your favorite loadouts into future side
quests and story missions you can also
find spartan cores which are spent to
upgrade chief's equipment from a
gameplay perspective the grapple shot is
the true star of infinite's campaign
though there are plenty of firearms
melee weapons and grenades for chief to
use and each tears through enemies with
a nice kinetic punch the grapple shot
fundamentally changes how you play a
halo game for the better in terms of
traversal a grappling hook makes chief
more nimble and opens up new vertical
pathways while exploring zeta halo but
the tool is far more valuable in combat
allowing you to grab far off firearms
when your current one runs out of ammo
pull you into range that chief can land
some solid hits or simply yank you out
of a firefight that's not going your way
it opens up brand new strategies for
handling old enemies too for instance
jackals will momentarily drop their
guard if you grapple and pull at their
shields
the grapple shot makes chief a faster
and more efficient killer you're still
doing the same loop of gunfire grenades
in melee and the dance of using your
shield to tank hits and taking cover
when said shield is broken is still the
same too but chief can storm through
enemies far more efficiently now adding
more strategic considerations to the
tried and true formula chief's remaining
equipment doesn't quite reach the same
highs as the grapple shot but they are
still valuable in combat each in their
own way enemies hit hard in the heroic
and legendary difficulties and mastering
how to use all of juice equipment opens
up new means of taking them on and
surviving oftentimes it can feel like
infinite is actively discouraging you
from engaging in the other equipment
though the grapple shot is unbelievably
useful in practically every situation
you have to temporarily switch away from
it to use chief's other equipment this
does lessen the impact of unlocking a
new ability as it's hard to get excited
over new equipment but i know i'm likely
only going to use it a few times that i
can keep the grapple shot ready in my
fight against the banished
the master chief returns
we thought you did
tossed
the war chief of the banished isn't all
that interesting as a principal
antagonist the dude's got an incredible
i am clearly the bad guy voice that
reverberates with a growling rumble
whenever he monologues but his
motivations don't really extend beyond
being the leader of a group of
bloodthirsty killers prior to the events
of infinite the banished wage to
months-long war on the unesc that saw
their leader psychologically and
physically dismantle the human military
soldiers and spartans but none of that
absolutely evil energy is present in
infinite resulting in a villain who's
hard to care about instead the
intriguing characterization is reserved
for chief the weapon and the pilot the
trio form a family unit with chief at
the head this setup affords some
incredible insight into chief psyche as
the armored warriors confronted with two
allies who aren't career soldiers a
truly incredible scene partway through
the game sees the pilot and chief
confront each other and what follows is
a rare moment of vulnerability that
humanizes chief in an unexpected and
meaningful way scenes like this are
sprinkled throughout the campaign as
chief the pilot and the weapon all
confront their own humanity and their
innate responsibility to each other one
moment in particular however does not
land part way through infinite chief
takes away the weapon's agency in an
incredibly problematic way the weapon is
understandably upset at the betrayal and
lashes out of chief's callousness only
for her to quickly soften and forgive
chief upon learning his motivations it
feels like a rushed development and one
that unfortunately implies that if they
have a good reason dads have a
responsibility to decide a child's
entire life the second said child steps
out of line the whole thing isn't
resolved in a great way while the
quality of writing may occasionally dip
each key scene is always bolstered by
infinite superb soundtrack the nature of
the hybrid open world means that most of
infinite's major story beats and the
conversations between characters occur
in set locations and so the orchestral
score can be carefully timed with the
game's most poignant moments there has
yet to be a mainline halo game with
anything less than an absolute banger of
a musical score and infinite does not
buck that trend the rich soundtrack is
helped along by the equally impressive
level of detail through for the
industries has achieved with facial
expressions on xbox series x having a
rousing score accompanied by believable
acting and expressions means there is a
collection of genuinely epic and tragic
moments in infinite that really land
halo infinite strives to transform what
it means to be a halo game making chief
into a reluctant father figure for a
young and naive ai and putting him into
an open world setting turns out that was
a risk worth taking for the franchise as
infinite is an incredible game there are
flaws but this is the best halo campaign
in years certain story elements are on
the weaker side and the amazing grapple
shot makes the rest of chief's equipment
feel a bit lacking in comparison but
these are small shortcomings what
otherwise feels like the right step for
halo to take going
forward eyes up reinforcements